.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BIG BREAKING NEWS ON MULTIPLE
FRONTS TONIGHT INCLUDING ANOTHER
DISMAL DAY ON WALL STREET,
REALLY DISASTROUS ACTUALLY.
AMERICANS ARE NOW WATCHING THEIR
401(K)s SUFFER UNDER BIDEN'S
ECONOMIC DENIAL.
THE RECESSION IS NOT COMING.
THE RECESSION IS HERE AND WE
WILL BREAK IT ALL DOWN.
THAT'S COMING UP TONIGHT.
ALSO TONIGHT MORE WARNING SIGNS
FOR THE EXTREME SOCIALIST
PENNSYLVANIA SENATE CANDIDATE,
THE GUY WITH THE TATTOOS AND THE
HOODIE THAT NEVER WORKED A REAL
JOB IN HIS LIFE, TRUST FUND
BRAT, JOHN FETTERMAN.
IT'S GONE FROM BAD TO WORSE AND
IT'S GETTING HARD TO WATCH.
WE WILL PLAY THE TAPE.
ALSO WE HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH CONGRESSMAN
MATT GAETZ AS CAREER PROSECUTORS
ARE REPORTEDLY RECOMMENDING NO
CHARGES IN THE INVESTIGATION
THAT HAS NOW CONSUMED HIS LIFE
FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS.
FIRST WITH JUST 46 DAYS UNTIL
THE CRITICAL, WELL, INFLECTION
POINT MIDTERM ELECTIONS, I WANT
TO TAKE A STEP BACK AND LAY OUT
EXACTLY WHAT IS AT STAKE.
AS I'VE BEEN TRYING TO SAY, THIS
MIGHT BE THE MOST IMPORTANT AND
CONSEQUENT ON MIDTERM ELECTION
OF OUR LIFETIME AND ITS CRITICAL
REPUBLICANS BE VERY CLEAR WITH
YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT
THEY BELIEVE IN, WHY THEY
BELIEVE IT, HOW THE CONSERVATIVE
AGENDA IS GOING TO DELIVER
RESULTS FOR AMERICANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT MOST NEED IT.
OUR COUNTRY IS IN TURMOIL.
WE HAVE A BROKEN BORDER, ALL
CAUSED BY JOE BIDEN, SURGING
INFLATION CAUSED BY JOE BIDEN, A
SINKING STOCK MARKET CAUSED BY
JOE BIDEN AND THE CLIMATE
ALARMIST CULT, RECESSION CAUSED
BY BIDEN AND COMPANY, SURGING
CRIME CAUSED BY THE DEFUND,
DISMANTLE, NO BAIL POLICE AGENDA
AMPLIFIED BY BIDEN AND HARRIS.
DECLINING AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
ALL CENTERED AROUND FRANKLY THE
DECREPIT, WEAK, FRAIL,
COGNITIVELY STRUGGLING
PRESIDENT.
UNDER DEMOCRATIC RULE,
HARDWORKING FAMILIES ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE SEEING CRIME UP,
COST OF LIVING UP, QUALITY OF
LIFE DOWN.
WE HAVE SHOWN YOU THE TRAGIC
STORIES, ONE CITY AFTER ANOTHER,
ONE SMALL TOWN AFTER ANOTHER.
THE DESTRUCTIVE DEMOCRATIC
AGENDA IS AN AGENDA HELL-BENT ON
DOUBLING DOWN ON THIS RADICAL
GREEN NEW DEAL SOCIALISM.
IN OTHER WORDS CLIMATE ALARMIST
CULTISM, ATTACKS ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT, FAR LEFT
INDOCTRINATION IN SCHOOLS.
OPEN BORDERS.
BY THE WAY, ALL DESTROYING
EVERYDAY LIFE IN AMERICA.
THERE IS GOOD NEWS BECAUSE TODAY
HOUSE REPUBLICANS FOLLOW THROUGH
ON THEIR PROMISE AND THEY
DECIDED FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 28
YEARS THEY PUT IN WRITING THEIR
COMMITMENTS TO YOU, THE VOTERS,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEIR COMMITMENTS TO BRING BACK
PROSPERITY AND WAGE GROWTH,
SECURITY TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
AND WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOW HOPEFULLY SOON TO BE
SPEAKER McCARTHY, HE UNVEILED
HIS COMMITMENTS TO AMERICA.
IT'S AN AREA CONFERENCE OF PLAN.
IT IS TO RESTORE AMERICAN
GREATNESS AND NOW WE CAN BRING
YOU THE EXCLUSIVE DETAILS.
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THE AGENDA IS DIVIDED INTO FOUR
MAJOR CATEGORIES.
AN ECONOMY THAT IS STRONG, A
NATION THAT IS SAFE, FUTURE THAT
IS BUILT ON FREEDOM, AND A
GOVERNMENT THAT IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
KEEP LOOKING AT YOUR SCREEN.
LOOK AT THE SUBCATEGORIES.
THIS IS AN AGENDA CENTERED
AROUND FIXING INFLATION ABOUT
SECURING THE BORDER, ENDING
SUPPLY CHAIN DEPENDENCE,
STOPPING THE FLOW OF SENTINEL
AND OPIOIDS POURING INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
BOLSTERING PARENTAL RIGHTS IN
SCHOOLS, CONFRONTING BIG TECH
BIAS, RETURNING TO AMERICAN
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, RESTORING
SAFETY AND SECURITY SO WE CAN
PURSUE HAPPINESS WITHOUT FEAR
AND PROSPERITY BROUGHT BACK FOR
WORKING FAMILIES ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
CONTRAST THE AGENDA WITH THE
NEVER-ENDING FAILURES OF
JOE BIDEN, THE CLIMATE CULTISTS,
AND THEN ASK YOURSELF.
IS THERE ONE THING JOE BIDEN,
THAT YOU CAN POINT TO THAT HE'S
DONE, TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE THE
COUNTRY?
IS THERE ONE THING?
THE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS HAVE
DONE TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE YOUR
LIFE?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF SINCE
JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TAKEN OVER EVERY CORNER OF THE
GOVERNMENT SINCE HE'S BECOME
PRESIDENT.
SINCE THE GREEN NEW DEAL CLIMATE
CULTISTS HAVE TAKEN OVER EVERY
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
IT'S BEEN RECKLESS SPENDING
AFTER RECKLESS SPENDING, COVID
BILL THAT WAS NEVER FOR COVID.
REDUCTION ACT THAT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH REDUCING INFLATION.
ONE SLEIGHT-OF-HAND, ONE BAIT
AND SWITCH AFTER ANOTHER ALL
WHILE DEMOCRATS CALL YOU
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS FOR WANTING
CHOICE IN EDUCATION AND SPEAKING
UP AT SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
WANTING TRANSPARENCY IN SCHOOL.
JOE BIDEN CALLS YOU AN ENEMY OF
THE STATE, A MAGA REPUBLICAN.
BECAUSE YOU WANT A SECURE
BORDER, ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, BY
THE WAY THOSE HIGHER PRICES
RESULTING HIGHER PRICES TO
DELIVER GOODS TO EVERY STORE YOU
GO TO, EVERY STORE YOU GO TO,
YOU ARE PAYING MORE THAN YOU
SHOULD.
JOE IS FORCING AMERICANS TO PAY
OFF STUDENT LOANS EVEN FOR KIDS
GOING TO HARVARD AND YALE AND
CORNELL, DARTMOUTH, YOU NAME IT.
COURSE JOE BIDEN IS IN A NEVER
ENDING FIGHT WITH REALITY.
HE DOESN'T THINK THERE'S A
RECESSION.
THERE IS ONE.
HE DOESN'T THINK THERE'S A
BORDER CRISIS.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
HE ACTUALLY THINKS HIS AGENDA IS
WORKING.
46 DAYS, YOU'LL GET THE FINAL
SAY TO DETERMINE WHETHER WE GO
DOWN THE BROKEN ROAD OF
JOE BIDEN AND THE NEW EXTREME
RADICAL SOCIALISTS OR TURN TO
THE AMERICAN FIRST PROSPERITY
ACHIEVED UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP
UNDER A NEW ERA OF CONSERVATIVE
LEADERSHIP WITHIN NEW REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY HOPEFULLY IN THE HOUS